- What's up! What's going on?
- [Kelly] Okay. First of
all, you look fabulous,
but you smell even better!
I don't know what you're wearing.
- Little bit of Creed.
- It smells so good!
- Yeah, man.
- I was like, I like that smell.
- [Samson] Appreciate it.
- Have you met Tiffany before?
- Yeah, we met a few weeks
back at the CAA party.
- Yo I can smell him through the internet,
I can smell him through the internet.
- [Kelly] That's good.
I was like, I was like.
- We met at a party
through one of my friends.
Damson introduced us briefly.
This was about a month ago.
- Oh, okay, right on. Random.
We're just bringing y'all together again.
- [Tiffany] Oh! When we
was singing and dancing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- She's like, I'm recalling.
So your show is called
"Our Flag Means Death".
- Yes.
- So, it's a pirate show, obviously.
- [Samson] Yes.
- Okay, so what's like the
premise of it for everybody?
- So it's basically a pirate show
about this wealthy landowner
called Stede Bonnet,
who I found out was a real person
when I was playing Assassin's
Creed on PlayStation.
- Yeah (laughs). I love you.
- I remember I was
playing it and I was like,
I was like, hold on
this guy, Stede Bonnet.
I was like, oh! He's
in the show. And then-
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And that was my reference.
So I just kept playing Assassin's Creed
to learn about "Our Flag
Means Death". Method.
Yeah, so he's a wealthy landowner
who kind of gives up his life
as a rich, you know, dude,
and sets sail to become a pirate
because he's quite bored
of his regular life.
And I play Oluwande, who
is a journeyman pirate
who's kind of looking for
like an easy life at sea.
- Yeah.
- But his bestie, Jim,
has more vengeful ideas.
So we join this crew
and go on this journey
because we get paid like a wage and stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And back then pirates didn't
get paid a wage, I think.
- Until you stole something from somebody.
- And they just stole. They
just stole, pillaged and killed.
So, we have a nine to five.
- I love that like, I laughed,
I chuckled about that,
and then it's like,
that's horrible actually.
Like, but I was like ha ha ha
because they killed people.
- Ha ha. They died! They kill! They steal!
- That was like really weird.
I feel awkward about it now, yeah.
I was like, it's not funny.
So wait, so have you ever
tried to like pirate anything,
or like smuggle anything in? Like, I do.
And just so you know, if you
see me at a movie theater
I have totally something in my bag.
- [Samson] Yeah.
- Because it's not that
I'm not willing to pay.
- Me too!
- Yes!
- I stay with food in my bag, girl.
- [Kelly] Me too!
- At all events. If I got a
bag, there is food in it, honey.
- Yes! And that's my thing is like,
it's not even that I'm not
willing at this point in my life.
Like earlier, yeah, I couldn't afford it,
the concession stands are really pricey,
but I can afford it now, but
they never have what I want.
- [Samson] Yeah.
- And so I smuggle in what I want.
So you smuggle in, I heard,
these kind of cookies.
- Oh gosh, yeah! So when I
was coming, this was like,
I think it was like two, three years ago.
I was coming to LA and I love -
there's these biscuits, right,
that we call Jammie Dodgers.
And I love them, they're
like my favorite biscuits.
- Which your biscuits are
cookies to us, right yeah?
- Yeah, yeah they're cookies. Mmm.
- [Kelly] Biscuits. I like it.
- And then.
- See biscuits to us are
like, biscuits in the morning
with some honey on it and butter.
- Yeah you lot's biscuits is
bread, it's like a bread roll.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's hot.
- [Kelly] But I'll take either one, yeah.
- Yeah (laughs).
- So what kinda cookie is it?
- So it's like a raspberry ring cookie.
So what I did is, I put
it in my hand luggage.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I come to the security
bit, and the guy looked at it
and he, for some reason he stopped my bag,
and he looked in my bag.
And he was like, hey mate,
why have you got 22
packs of biscuits here?
And I was like, 'cause I'm hungry.
And he was like well, I
mean, I know, but there's 22.
And I was like, well, I'm gonna
be here for a little while.
Then he went round the back
to check if there was drugs in the cookies
and he came back and there was
19 back when I got it back.
And crumbs on his lip.
(Samson & audience laughing)
And I was like, and then
I walked through security
I was like, all right I see you, yeah.
And then I kept it moving
'cause I didn't wanna go home.
- Have you, Tiffany,
have you ever had to give anything back?
Like you didn't know it
was in your bag at like,
a security checkpoint?
That happened to you?
- Hairspray for me. They
always take my hairspray.
- [Kelly] They do?
- That's a big kind of hairspray.
- Yeah, that can reminded
me like back in the day.
- I used to have a lot of hair, man.
I used to have a lot of hair.
- I actually love the-
- Are these the cookies
he was talking about?
- [Samson] Yo!
- Wait, I know, I see cookies, I want one.
- What'd you think? What'd you think?
- Wait, I want one.
Justin, thank you. Okay.
- Yo. Now, you lot have
to try these cookies.
- Since you're forcing me.
- [Tiffany] They taste like-
- I wanna get to the raspberry.
- It tastes like heaven.
- Those are good.
- Taste's like grandma cookie,
like stuff your grandma
have on the coffee table
when you come up into the house.
- [Samson] Yeah, yeah.
- With some hot cocoa.
- Oh, I love hot cocoa too.
See, this is a good show. Okay.
So, "Our Flag Means Death" is through -
you win with this cookie,
though, you brought cookies,
so you're welcome to this show anytime.
- [Samson] Cheers.
- Just so you know.
- I'm in now.
- [Kelly] You are in.